I have found the Dragon Ball equivalent
of Laurel Yanni I have shown this clip
to multiple people and have gotten no
consensus whatsoever so let's see what
you guys think listen to this clip
you've left even your precious Dragon
Balls unguarded well I assure you it
will be your last mistake so when I
first listened to this clip I heard her
last mistake which is obviously funny
given how many people used to think
Frieza was a girl but then as I went
back and listened I realized that the
line is probably your last mistake with
just a bit of breathiness on the your it
will be your last mistake but here's the
thing some of my friends cannot hear
your and some of them can't hear her
I've actually gotten to the point now
where I can purposely switch which one I
hear on command so sound off in the
comments down below which one do you
guys hear it will be your last mistake
[Music]